Franklin says fans are cancer for the
authentic individual well huh that's a
tough one you know I mean cancer no that
that's too that's too dramatic I mean I
guess that what you're pointing out is
the danger of Fame and and I can
certainly appreciate that I can't say
that I'm particularly comfortable with
it which might seem to be rather
hypocritical as it isn't like I've shied
away from exposing my views in public
but I felt that I was driven to that by
necessity and also by my desire to
educate people however I would say
despite the fact that I'm somewhat
uncomfortable with it I think that's
mostly because of the responsibility you
know and I've been terrified for a whole
year that I'd say something you know
unforgivably stupid and you know
demolish myself in public and and you
know feel guilty and horrible about that
for the rest of my life and so far I'd
be fortunate there's been some close
calls but I've been fortunate but you
know now when I go places people often
recognize me even at this little town we
went up to this weekend there were two
people that came up to me in the parking
lot and we're excited to meet me and you
know the vast majority of encounters all
of the encounters I have with people in
public have been really wonderful I have
to say that the people have been
extremely friendly and you know
sometimes they're a bit starstruck which
I find strange I can see the projection
you know so it's it's unsettling for me
although I'm not judging anybody for it
it's just a strange thing to observe but
you know I can't complain about the fact
that people are are are are positively
predisposed to what I'm doing I mean
it's such a privilege I can't imagine
what it would be like to be hated
publicly I think that would just kill me
I really think that but so I mean it's
it's I suppose there's the possibility
of having that sort of thing go to your
head and it's it and I mean that happens
to people but
I think I've said this before maybe on
the q and A's I have a pretty sensible
family and I have a pretty what would
you say I have a pretty good sense of my
limitations I would say let's we could
even call it an acute sense and so I'm
not particularly worried that this is
going to go to my head in some way that
that would you know inflate my ego or
something like that huh I mean I think
one of the things I have noticed is that
I might be a little less patient with
people when I'm speaking because I'm
more used to that more use to them might
be good for me to be listened to and so
I have to watch that but I'm pretty I've
always been pretty noisy and talkative
and so that's probably something that's
plagued me or being a characteristic of
me ever since I was a little tiny kid I
mean I used to talk all the time when I
was a little little little guy I mean I
think my cousin Eric poni --the he
probably listens to this he used to call
me motormouth and that was about exactly
right I was like a miniature Camille
Paglia
so anyways I can't complain about having
let's say fans I people have been
unbelievably good to me and I'm really
grateful for that so